Please take a look at DC's teacher of the year.
Aiton Elementary is a school in Washington, DC.
It is in ward seven, Northeast DC.
This community has been underserved for several years.
However, this community is filled with such cultural wealth.
My personal mission always has been to
give my students access to a variety of
people, programs, resources, and connections
to really enhance their learning experience.
We actually reached out to Asus
and they are giving us enough Asus Chromebooks
for every single student and teacher
at Aiton Elementary.
(cheering and applause)
I can't even fathom this.
This is crazy.
That was
Alejandro Diasgranados,
a teacher at Aiton Elementary.
And today, we have sent ABC7 reporter Kid O'Shea
to his house
for what Alejandro thinks is just a quick follow-up.
But, we actually have a very special surprise.
Are you guys ready?
(Cheering and applause).
All right, let's do this.
Hi guys.
Hi!
Hi, Drew.
We are here with Alejandro, or as his students
at Aiton Elementary know him as:
Mr. Diaz.
It's good to see you Drew!
Hi Alejandro.
I'm so happy to see you.
What an incredible year you are having.
After we did our show together,
you won a very important award.
I did.
So after our show, I was nominated and chosen
for the DC Teacher of the Year.
(Applause and cheering).
And I just recently found out that I was also selected
as a finalist for the National Teacher of the Year award,
as well as the National University award, you know.
So it has been incredible, you know, for teachers to
be recognized during a time when, you know,
teachers are working so hard.
So I'm just grateful and happy to even be able to
receive that.
And you've done so much to work with your kids
in the classroom and keep them engaged during these times.
Tell us about some of the stuff that you've been doing
with them at school.
Yeah, I mean, so we've been virtual and some
of the things that we do, I mean, we have so much fun.
We, the students do yoga, they bring their pets on screen.
So they got to meet my dog Margo, and I get to meet
like their pet snake Gizmo.
And we just do all types of incredible things.
You know, today we met with the embassy of Uganda as well.
So, you know
they are just, just great to have in the classroom.
That's so awesome.
And Alejandro,
like what does the National University Teacher
award nomination mean to you?
Yeah, so the National University Teacher award
is incredible.
That was the first time I was even recognized
for any sort of award.
And, you know, it is so huge, because, you know
teachers are working so hard
during this pandemic, and to even be recognized
is something I'm just extremely grateful for.
And, you know, teachers work so hard
and I wasn't even inspired to become a teacher
if it wasn't for one of my former teachers
Mr. Harris, from my middle school.
You know, he would come in every single day
with a shirt and tie and, you know, had a fresh haircut.
And this was my first teacher who resembled my background.
So that really inspired me to become a teacher and
you know, National University focuses
and highlights inspiring teachers.
So, you know, it's just incredible.
And I'm being told actually right now
that we actually have an update from
that, about the award.
And I think we can bring in
Dr. Michael Cunningham from National University.
Are you there?
I'm here.
Hello everyone.
Hi Drew. Hi everybody.
Hello.
[Dr. Michael Cunningham] So Alejandro,
it is indeed my pleasure to announce
that you have been selected
as the grand winner of the National University Teacher
of the Year award.
(Applause and cheering).
[Dr. Michael Cunningham] Alejandro, let me tell you.
We chose you because you believe
and inspire your students each and every day.
Now I have some more good news.
As the winner,
you just received this $50,000 check,
which you can spend any way you want.
And you also will receive
a full ride scholarship
to the Social and Emotional masters program at
National University.
(Applause and cheering).
So congratulations, stay safe.
Keep up the good work.
I am in complete shock.
[Dr. Michael Cunningham] Thank you, stay safe.
You're holding a $50,000 check right now.
I am at a loss for words.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Wow. I can't, I just don't know what to say.
I mean, you know, I've had inspirational teachers
in my life who have, you know
really have worked hard to make sure
that I'm in the place where I am now.
So I'm just extremely grateful.
Drew, you know, National University.
I really, really appreciate this.
This is really incredible.
Thank you, Dr. Cunningham
so much
for doing this with us
on this show.
Oh my god.
[Drew] So, thank you for letting our show be a part
of your prestigious recognition of Alejandro.
Thank you, Dr. Cunningham, so much.
My pleasure.
Keep up the great work Alejandro!
(Applause and cheering).
Thank you Dr. Cunningham, so, so much.
And I got to give it up to my dear friend,
Kidd O'Shea, who is like literally
the one who helped us pull this off,
and it is so nice to be
working with you and let this please be the beginning
of many elaborate cool schemes we do together.
I love it.
How does it feel?
I'm in shock.
Drew, how did you keep this a secret?
How did- I just had no idea.
I mean, I'm just so appreciative Drew.
I mean, we are like best friends now,
and tell Douglas I said hello.
It's true.
Let's keep the good times rolling please.
And Kidd,
thank you so much.
And my deepest appreciation to Dr. Cunningham.
Go to our website to find out more
about the National University
and how to nominate a teacher in your community.
You guys, you are the best.
Congratulations. I'll see you soon.